Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into the mailbag.
Also known as Friday Feedback, also known
as the Friday Feed bag notturno.
You can email info at David Pakman.
Com.
Leave a YouTube comment, Send a tweet.
Whatever the case may be, your commentary
might end up featured in the segment.
We will start with William Sutherland, who
suggested via a YouTube comment to my entire
audience.
People go watch Jimmy Dore, someone who talks
truth, not this B.S.
And you know what?
If this comment resonates with you.
I am not going to try to convince you otherwise.
One of the things I'm actively not going to
do on the program is try to convince people
about why or whether they should watch or
listen to me or anybody else.
If to you if you go over to Jimmy Dawes channel
and you say, you know, it looks to me like
Jimmy Dore is telling the truth and David
Pakman is, quote, lying.
That's great.
Go watch Jimmy Dore.
Leave me alone.
I'm not going to be offended whatsoever.
Okay.
I would love for you to do that.
Marvin Hitler commented on YouTube, quote,
To be atheist, you have to acknowledge there
is a God for you not to belive in.
Therefore you're wrong.
You're not an atheist.
This is painfully stupid.
If I don't believe in purple unicorns.
Does that mean that I there must be a purple
unicorn out there somewhere for me not to
believe in it.
No, that doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
This is the type of nonsense that ends up
becoming a meme and repeated and repeated
and repeated.
And if you take one second to think about
it, you realize it doesn't make a shred of
sense whatsoever.
To be an atheist, you have to acknowledge
there is a God.
No, you don't.
Doesn't really make any sense.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
A grimace posted to the subreddit about my
book recommendation Waves of Ranker and says
David mentioned this book on a show last week.
I was able to hunt down a copy.
Holy cow.
Reading this book is eye opening.
It was published in 99.
And the stuff they talk about how the far
right are indoctrinated is insane.
They still use the same techniques today.
I highly recommend that I would buy a used
copy or find a means of getting a less expensive
digital copy.
This is fantastic.
This really you know how it's like you can
you can get anything right now.
You can find any random book This book is
genuinely tough to get.
I ended up getting a used hardcover copy.
Looks like an old school library book.
I think it might have been a library book
at some point and I didn't.
I didn't remember.
The book is from 99.
I thought it was even older.
If you want to trace how right wing media
got to where it is today and right wing indoctrination
got to where it is today.
You have to understand how it started.
And this book, Waves of Rancor, goes back
to the way in which talk radio originally
ended up on AM radio.
The degree to which right wing religious broadcasters
sucked up a bunch of the licenses for broadcasting
all the way through and into Fox News.
If you really want to understand how our media
got to where it is today, such an important
book and I love that Grimace was able to find
a copy also from the subreddit mat lately
says, Does anybody else reflexively say Troth
Essential or Lauren Boebert?
I watched too many of his meaning my videos
that the wrong pronunciations are permanently
stuck in my head.
Yeah, the same thing happens to me sometimes
when when Trump goes at a speech and he says
they should really be investigating Biden
and Hillary and even Obama.
Speaker 4: Obama.
Now.
Speaker 1: I will sometimes almost feel like
Trump got it wrong by saying Obama instead
of Obama.
They are.
They're extraordinarily meme worthy little
snippets.
And I apologize if now they're in people's
heads in that way.
Okay.
Also from the subreddit, this is from a user
named Cool Customer.
This gets me back to do people watch what?
I watch the videos before commenting?
Do people listen to what I say before commenting?
I recently did a segment about Bobby Kennedy
Jr's candidacy saying This guy is an anti-vax
dude.
He's using pro-Putin talking points.
No one should vote for him.
And yes, I once had dinner with him and we
have mutual friends.
Look at the posts that showed up on my subreddit.
David shouldn't whitewash Bobby Kennedy Jr.
I understand there's a personal progressive
connection there, but in my opinion, David
shouldn't cover for his anti-vaccine history.
He didn't become anti-vaccine during the pandemic.
He's been anti-vax since 2005.
In fact, he runs one of the largest vaccine
disinformation campaigns, Children's Health
Defense.
He's done an inordinate amount of damage to
public health.
Okay.
So anyway, the point here is the did you even
listen to what I had to say?
I didn't whitewash it.
In fact, what I said was, despite the fact
that this is a little awkward because I've
met Bobby Kennedy Jr and we had dinner once
and we have friends in common.
His candidacy is a disaster.
He's an unmitigated anti-vaxxer.
He's going on TV.
He went on Tucker before Tucker was fired
and used pro-Putin talking points.
This is a disaster.
And by the way, Steve Bannon loves the idea
of Bobby Kennedy running as a, quote, chaos
agent.
And it's all the nonsense.
I didn't whitewash anything.
In fact, I said, despite personal connections,
I think that this campaign is an absolute
and total disaster.
So please criticize me for things I've said,
not things I haven't said.
The Bobby Kennedy candidacy is a disaster,
without a doubt.
Okay.
John commented on YouTube.
Just remember the same people who want to
ban clothing they don't think is appropriate
are almost always the same people who wanted
to ban masks during a worldwide deadly pandemic.
It's more about their personal feelings over
those of anyone else.
Yeah, this goes to this idea that Ben SHAPIRO
talked about the idea of banning people from
wearing clothes that don't align with the
traditional clothes worn by their gender.
And it explained it makes absolutely no sense.
And then the Department of Agriculture, I
believe it was in Texas, we talked about it
last week, is looking to put in a policy where
you have to dress in accordance with the traditional
clothing of your gender.
It is, you know, the same people who talk
about how great freedom is and liberty and
government not getting involved in people's
lives are now saying, we're going to decide
what you wear.
They are the same.
To some degree, they are the same folks that
were saying no masks, ban masks, whatever,
and then going to leave the masking to a personal
choice, but not the clothing will decide what
clothing you can wear, but leave the masking
to a personal choice.
These are serious people.
That's really, at the end of the day, the
most important thing to understand.
These are not serious individuals who bring
real thought to the table.
They reflexively will say whatever they think
at that particular moment is useful to achieve
whatever immediate goal they have, even if
it conflicts with whatever they said a week
ago.
A user sassy Nana, asks a really great question
about these ideas of sending homeless people
to encampments outside cities for rehabilitation
of different kinds.
Sassy Nana says, How do you rehabilitate a
homeless single mother who works full time
at Subway but can't afford an apartment?
And of course, that is an absolutely accurate
critique of this idea that Trump has about
we're going to get them seen by doctors and
psychiatrists and we're going to get them
off drugs and all these different things.
Tons of homeless people.
Are working or very recently were working.
And either way, sending them outside of a
city will either make them unable to continue
working or make it dramatically more difficult
for them to get a job any time soon.
It's a disastrous idea.
The Homeless encampment idea has recent examples
of how it's failed and more distant in history,
examples of how it's failed.
It's inhumane.
The conditions always become ridiculously
humiliatingly bad, dangerously bad, and the
crowd tears whenever Trump brings it up.
So it is very, very scary stuff.
If you have anything you want to say, feedback
on the show, criticisms, praise, whatever.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
or leave a comment on any of our various social
media platforms.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
The show doesn't have to end right now.
If you're not a member, there's no more show
until next Monday.
If you are a member, we have the bonus show
coming right up.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
make absolutely sure that you know the coupon
code indicted is available to you.
And I think it's a it's like a 50% discount
off of the cost of membership.
Join Pacman dot com.
See you on the bottom.
Yes.